what is happening this looks insane
take the deal Scott just let Kang be
your guide
these are daddy he'll get us home
you want to know how you got these scars
yeah I want to know about these scars
I do want to know I do want to know
that's what we'll talk about it we're
gonna figure it out we're not gonna wait
for the movie we're gonna get our own
answers God damn it welcome back to new
rock stars King the Conqueror has
arrived at the MCU in the first trailer
for Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
with Jonathan Majors showing his face as
a far more dangerous variant in the
trickster he who remains that we met in
Loki but this face is lined with scars
from past Wars not just like random
comic book lines on the comic book
version of the character but it looks
like actual Scar Tissue suggesting some
backstory uh and like the greatest DC
movie villain of all time Kang as a
Multiverse man has a story behind his
scars that truly is multiple choice
Welcome To The King
I'm so glad Mt is not here for this
empty so
Marvel new rock stars weekly Marvel
reaction show we are now in the interim
weeks between Marvel's TV series and
this week we are taking quantumania by
storm and uh we're wondering who gave
Kang his scars American boss Mt is on a
well-deserved vacation this week we miss
empty we hope you're resting up and that
you're enjoying your time off uh and we
can't wait for you to come back uh and I
am here with my good friend Jessica
Clemons to talk about Quantum media hi
hey hey this is a fascinating week lots
of Marvel news is coming out uh and
we're now looking ahead to phase five
and how the Multiverse Saga is beginning
uh so Jess what are we talking about
coming out of this trailer how did Kane
get his scars which I think is actually
genuinely the number one question that
everyone's been asking yeah I mean
that's I
I do like because I saw this footage at
d23 and I didn't really notice that the
they were there but now were they not
there in the d23 footage and now they
are there in this one
oh that's what that's what Brandon was
saying he was like a d23 they didn't
have the scars but now they do have the
scars
interesting maybe that's why I didn't
see them yeah because I feel like people
would have noticed we saw it on these
huge screens uh there were some like I
think some uh I don't know how people in
that audience recorded it but were able
to record it from like a really terrible
angle and you could kind of see maybe
this that was Comic-Con but they police
you pretty hard uh when they show that
footage they have like seriously there's
a patrol of like maybe 30 men
intimidating looking men in dark suits
who just kind of like comb every aisle
looking at every single person and if
you even have your phone in your hand
they'll be like can you put your phone
away please and there it's like they
keep a lid on this stuff I have a piece
by their Security operation oh my God
I'd be so scared I'd honestly be so
scared I wouldn't even have my phone out
I'd be like I'm just gonna get tackled
at any moment yeah I'm off the grid I'm
off the grin at d23 all right Kang's
scars uh so this is obviously a choice
right so if they did take the effort to
VFX it into are going to have some
backstory behind that and I think to
understand maybe how this Kang might
have gotten these scars let's quickly
catch up on what we know of the history
of Kang and his variants in the MCU thus
far so in the Loki finale he who remains
talks about his background as a
scientist from the 31st century and I'm
just going to quickly read exactly what
he says because anytime we try to show
these clips Jonathan Majors just Savers
his delivery of it to put these long
little pauses and and tangents in there
and it's just a delight to watch but I'm
just trying to get to the basics of what
exactly he said I'm like going to be
like the stenographer reading back the
transfer he said I've been dubbed many
names by many people a ruler a conqueror
he who remains a jerk but it's not as
simple as the name inside real quick I
wonder is it gonna be like Scott who
calls him a jerk in this movie and since
time is a flat circle he remains is
referring to that yeah
I'm going crazy it's just a jerk sounds
like something
a jerk 100 and also honestly a missed
opportunity but maybe they didn't catch
that flag like you did so missed
opportunity if they don't do it right
you still have time it can be reached if
we can get uh you know certain uh DC
superhero in a post-credit scene in
Another Universe within weeks of the
movie's release you can make anything
happen in Marvel he remains goes on to
say eons ago before the TPA a variant of
myself lived on Earth in the 31st
Century he was a scientist and
discovered that there were universes
stacked on top of his own and we see
like rings of universes stacked on top
of each other at the same time other
versions of us were learning the same
thing naturally they made contact and
for a while there was peace narcissistic
self-congratulatory piece they shared
technology and knowledge using the best
of their universes to improve the others
however not every version of me was so
pure of heart to some of us new worlds
meant only one thing new lands to be
conquered the peace between realities
erupted in all-out war each variant
fighting to preserve their universe and
annihilate the others this was almost
the end of everything and everyone that
first variant encountered a creature
created from all the terrors in reality
capable of consuming time and space
itself a creature you both know Elias I
harness the beast's power and began
experimenting on it I weaponized eliaith
and I ended I ended the multiversal war
once I isolated our timeline all I had
to do was manage the flow of time and
prevent any further branches hence the
TBA hence the timekeepers in a highly
efficient bureaucracy hence ages and
ages of cosmic Harmony hence you're
welcome you came to kill the devil right
well guess what I keep you safe and if
you think I'm evil well just wait to
meet my variants and that's the Gambit
stifling order or cataclysmic chaos you
may hate the dictator but something far
worse is going to fill that void if you
depose of him obviously my delivery of
it doesn't even come close to John it
was so good the hence you're welcome
oh you're welcome and he when he talks
about that's a self-congratulatory
narcissistic piece oh I love your hair
love your shoes I just love every little
thing she puts into that monologue he's
such a good actor he was having so much
fun in that part in Loki I loved it oh I
know if anything I'm glad that that was
like the first Kang variant we met yes
he was just kind of like a Fiddler on
the Roof he's just like a giddy little
uh Scamp and I love him like just
because we're gonna see so many
different like the one in Quantum Mania
almost seems a little like Kang or uh
Thanos like uh by contrast yeah you know
yeah we'll probably get into this but
essentially I was like yeah he I feel
like he was the one that got put there
that got banished to the quantum Realm
by one of the other kings and now he's
stuck there yeah I think that's that's
very possible uh he who remains and did
the multiversal war he destroyed all the
other kings so why would he be worried
about his variants well it's because he
didn't fully eradicate all other kings
for all the future like he needed to
constantly maintain the sacred timeline
to keep new branches from forming that
would inevitably lead to New Kings so as
he warned Sylvie if he remains gets
taken out new branches will form that
will allow New Kings to flood into
existence and they'll just they'll
already be there uh biggest time is a
flat circle so uh was quantumania Kang
the exception to he remains blockade was
he just someone who like got away from
that multiversal war or does his Rising
threat now prove he remains point I
think it's the latter I think it's the
fact that they now that we now have to
worry about getting the quantum realm is
exactly what he remains warned us about
we are now living in a reality where it
can was able to entrap Scott and Cassie
hope Hank and Janet in the quantum realm
due to an accident that otherwise would
not have happened Cassie's device
malfunctioned now as a result of what
Sylvie did and I think it malfunctions
because it is powered with Quantum fuel
given to her by a new friend and she
says we built this who is we I think
it's Nathan I think it's Nathaniel
Richards yes a kid secretly for the
future an unaware Kang variance AKA iron
lad of the Young Avengers Iron Ladd was
one of the branches formed by Sylvie
killing who remains do you think that he
intentionally did it because we know in
the comics he didn't want to be a king
eventually he was like I know I'm gonna
be king and I don't want to be gang I
think it was in secret War where he
realized like I don't want to be king
this was like a will
consent team like I'm gonna [ __ ] up her
life or I'm gonna mess up her life sorry
bleep that out I think he was uh yeah it
doesn't Ireland be like
um I need to leave and he like flies
into the Sun or some [ __ ] no I love him
I love him Crossing streams no um they
uh yeah he I don't think he did it
intentionally I think Iron Man's gonna
be a period of heart person but he might
have had some kind of like
you know maybe Kang knew that his
collaboration with Cassie would lead to
this oh my future Kang knew that young
Kang would be like hey I'm just trying
to make friends and like hey she's an
engineer I'm an engineer why don't we
just like hook up I don't think uh young
Nathaniel did this on purpose I love it
it's just like he's just following his
natural destined protocol of like
helping people Share technology and
that's what we find out that that was
the origin story for all nathana
Richards is they just want to meet
like-minded engineers and scientists and
share to help improve their worlds
that's their Destin path and then it
always leads to a tragic twist maybe
young Nathaniel doesn't know that but
old Nathaniel does and that's what old
Nathaniel used against the Ant-Man
family um that's my Approach on this
anyway I love that and I'm I completely
abide by that and I love it and I have
nothing I don't disagree with any of it
do you think there's something until
we're proven yes
I'm gonna go with that until I'm proven
wrong
um do you think so do you think there's
other kangs in the quantum realm with
the King that we saw the scarred King is
the scar King the same as the purple
face cake blueface King I think it is
because my take on the blue faces that's
a mask that's like you know how the
Guardians of the Galaxy have the oxygen
uh preserver Mass that's just slightly
blue intent I think his is just thicker
and more protective from uh from enemy
attacks
um and that mask actually leads into my
theory of how can got those scars
exactly oh okay so quantumania Kang said
in the d23 trailer that he killed
countless Avengers so many that they
start to blend together and the lines on
King's face are just you know they're
just facial features that Kang always
really has in the comics but here they
are scar tissue and I think that's going
to be how MCU the MCU distinguishes
future kanks like we might see different
scarring on different kangs to Signal
different battles that they fought and
different Avengers that was like The
Last Avenger that they killed and left
them with that scar so we may see one
that has like three slashes across the
face foreign
[Music]
that has a big mjolnir imprint that has
like oh that'd be fine you know the that
those runes that ring of runes that may
just be imprinted on his face someone
just got walloped in the face so uh he
remains of course again won the
multiversal war with Elias he has no
scars uh because he just use Eliot but
the others walked away with scars so
here's my pitch I think these scars with
the even lines that run vertically down
the face I think these were given to him
by Cyclops Scott Summers I don't think
he took a direct hit but Cyclops hit him
with an optic blast that hit that blue
face shield and the blast was so strong
that it burned partially through the
mask just to leave Kang with some
permanent scar tissue in that particular
shape
that's probably a reach I understand I'm
just trying to think that would be a
cool explanation that would be how we
got scars that look exactly like that I
went back to the video just to watch
back his cars I love that theory I love
that idea that like each each King will
have a different imprint based on who
they were fighting and what realm and
this one that we did see the one that we
saw in Loki doesn't because he used
someone else to fight for him I love the
idea of that I I'm like if they
introduce Cyclops that way honestly I'd
I'd warrant it and I'd be okay with it
because this is a big deal this is a
king and he's gonna rule the entire like
phase five into phase six so it's like
oh well Secret Wars isn't phase six
right or is it phase five Secret Wars is
I believe the end of phase six yeah so
he's gonna be throughout the entire
thing so to bring in Cyclops that way
that's insane that's an insane Theory
and I like it I like it though I've
never and I'll be honest with you when
I'm like that theory is a little too
crazy I like this Theory this theory is
genuinely very fun I was trying to think
like how else could he have gotten
specific scars that are perfectly
symmetrical like that like you have
Deadpool with his katanas that could
have just gone exactly like Deadpool's
not part of it yet it's like it could be
future events too that's what's so
mind-boggling about it like we may see
him receive these scars in a future
conflict with future Avengers and X-Men
and it all just kind of Loops back
because Kang's always exist time is a
flat circle causality is not a before
and after thing anymore do not I know
that we've been taught to think inside
the box with time but for this you
cannot just don't think of like forwards
or backwards it's like anything's
possible so is this the king that said
did I kill you like are you an Avenger
that I killed so this is the one this is
the one I said that could it have been
an Avenger like when they when he killed
the Avengers maybe one Avenger got a
good lick on him
um and I'm just thinking of like what
Universe would have like a different
Avenger a different Marvel character
that like could do that I guess no
because it's two lines it's not like
Hawkeye could like slash him with one up
his eye I mean it could also be like
Vision right like we know in the uh the
the 2017 Avengers Unleashed Kang War
comic storyline that I'm convinced is
going to be the most
uh present comic influence and the way
they do Kang and phase five
um vision is really like the brains of
the Avengers operation there he's the
one who's like we must locate Kang as a
baby and kill him as a baby and they're
all like whoa whoa Vision what and he's
like oh you know we ought to take Galen
Hitler as a baby can't we kill Kang
isn't it like it's a baby
and then like wasp wasp specifically is
the one who's like Fu vision and the
fact that like the original wasp Janet
Van Dyne is such a big part of this
story makes me think we're gonna see
something like that Janet and I'm
connected to everybody in the comic she
is literally always under everyone a
piece of me is like is it shaped like an
M could he be like Bishop could Kang be
a form of Bishop from X-Men I'm I'm
genuinely I'm looking so close it is
that Scar and I'm like does it make is
there arches are there arches like
McDonald's yeah because they connect
they don't it's it's he looks like scar
from The Lion King just two yeah I mean
are we looking at like was it
Wolverine's son Dawkin yeah has like
just the two or x23 has the two on her I
think I think you're completely right
and I want you to be right and for
storytelling purposes I think it would
be insane and so fun to be like he's got
the scars from prior MC like Marvel
characters that we just haven't met yet
so I think we're on the right track of
like who could that person be that gave
him that two slicks but there's just so
many people that use blades they use
swords
they could be cyclops's eyes like it it
could be anyone oh yeah I mean the way
the optic blast is fired out of his eyes
generally the big the Ruby quartz blast
they kind of meet to make one big
percussive beam but like they are coming
out of two different portals in his eyes
so if it's in close quarters if like
Kang through his telekinesis removed the
the focus lens they would be two
separate blasts that gets his face all
right I'm here for it do you think he
got blasted with the mask on or he's
wearing the mask now because of the
blast I think he got blasted with the
mask on but it was just so hot you know
if you're wearing a mask like if it's
just still that hot it's still gonna
scald you on the other side oh my God
but it's clean it's clean enough to
where it also makes me think it's just a
blade but I mean lasers are cleaner than
blades lasers is why they do LASIK
surgery but you think that laser would
have just made two perfect lines two
yeah perfect lines that's why I think
it's a blade that's why I'm like that
blade slice is deep it's deep and it's
that's what the scar tissue is it's the
skin it's the healing of the skin so
it's deep we would have to um I was
gonna say they'd have to be super
precise but we have some Swordsmen in
the MCU who are pretty precise I mean
that's what I was also thinking it's
just like claws so it's just like one
switch I'm I'm leaning Wolverine I'm
lean Wolverine now that we know that
he's coming into a Deadpool and maybe
they're gonna try to like lure that into
something else I don't know I'm leaning
more blades but like the third claw yeah
maybe we just missed his head a little
bit he got two of the three the two it
just kind of got in the face the third
one who the MCU like currently or past
could it have been like it uh Jacques
Duquesne I was like John or um or kit
harington's character
um a moon night
yeah yeah over sure Scarlet scrape I
mean hey that's why I say like you could
totally have uh you you could have had
Vision do this because vision
I like that idea I like that idea I love
the entire Theory it's perfect I think
it makes complete you're gonna have that
Green Goblin float in on his glider and
just kind of just keep doing it
completely up and just cut him in the
eye yeah oh yeah okay holds down
[Laughter]
I'm gonna lean I'd rather lean Cyclops
and vision before I lean the Hobgoblin
yeah so let us know in the comments
below how exactly you think because my
theory is that uh this movie won't
answer it and then we will see it happen
at some point in the future either in
like Loki season 2 or Kang Dynasty we'll
see a version of Kang receive those
scars we'll close the loop we'll
physically see it you don't think we'll
get the straight up Joker like you
looking at my face you want to know how
I got this you know they go again I
don't think we will I don't think we
will because I think it's a smarter move
to just like present the character this
way it's more what Marvel does is they
just kind of like give you something and
they let us speculate and then they
answer they don't um do we know the time
of when Ant-Man and Watson was taking
place on the timeline we don't we have
to assume that every new release comes
out in a specific like just in
chronological order unless they tell us
otherwise I'm trying to think of because
you know there's gonna be Disney Plus
shows that are going to take place like
before it and maybe we'll see like a
clean King and or like when Kane gets
his cards and I'm like that's him that's
the one from Ant-Man and like Quantum
video and I'm just gonna freak out oh I
love that I love this and we should note
that the big Kang statue on the in the
TDA did not have it didn't have scars so
there is another conqueror King who's
also unscarred unless that conquer King
is self-conscious about his scars and is
like I don't want to look like I've ever
taken damage before it's more fearsome
if I'm unscard I don't know that's true
maybe he's this guy that's like or the
scar the king that's a little insecure
so he just like powders over it uh or
he's like don't put it in my don't put
it in my statue uh but I like that's a
good note you are but you've been doing
this forever so I was like that makes
sense I was like I forgot about the
statue in Loki at the very end and it
doesn't have a scar is it pretty or
pretty pretty pretty cake pretty cake I
think all kings are pretty Kings that's
me
okay a few more questions we want to
dive into from this trailer first the
second season of the hit show DC's
Batman the audio Adventures is now out
on HBO Max uh Gotham City a seating
cauldron of crime and Corruption about
to boil over in the long shadow of
two-faced in the Penguins combined
criminal might Gotham City is gripped in
Twin fist of passion and Terror as
harlingenzel bulldozes a path through
her heart's desire and scarecrow floods
the city with new and improved nightmare
mirrors tune in for a tale of life and
death in Gotham City starring Jeffrey
Wright Rosario Dawson Bradley Whitford
Jillian Jacobs Keenan Thompson and Chris
Parnell friend of the channel Bobby
Moynihan plays the penguin he said in an
interview with TV Insider that it's the
role he's most proud of in his career
stream DC's Batman the audio Adventures
season two now on HBO Max we also want
to thank Brooklyn and for sponsoring
this episode holiday shopping can be
stressful in fact even saying that right
now in the month of October just sends a
shiver down my spine thankfully
brooklinen is the place to get presents
that are somehow perfect for all of your
people right on time and stress-free
Brooklyn strives to bring hotel level
Comfort home with sheets that are high
quality and offer premium coziness their
Lux satin sheets continue to be a
favorite for their buttery smooth finish
and perfect temperature for those who
sleep a little chilly and their weighted
blankets are like wrapping up in a hug
whenever you need it's the perfect size
to bring Comfort to any corner of your
space and just the right way to put your
mind and body at ease this Black Friday
Cyber Monday is a perfect time to commit
to the Comfort you're craving or gifting
because every bit of it is on sale and
the Brooklyn and Rewards program means
you actually get points for your
purchases too along with free shipping
and exclusive deals make your holidays
even happier with help from the
internet's favorite Brooklyn and
Brooklyn's Black Friday slide every
Monday sale is only for a limited time
and the deals don't get better than this
and if you happen to have missed out use
a promo code inside Marvel visit
brooklinen.com and get 20 off plus free
shipping on orders a hundred dollars or
more with the code inside Marvel that's
b-r-o-o-k-l-i-n-e-n.com okay uh so
another big question from the
quantumania trailer Jess is uh this
whole idea of what Kang lost and
specifically what Janet stole from him
it seems like it's her uh burden that
she's been burying and I just want to
ask you what or who do you think Kang
might have lost do you okay so remember
in Ant-Man and was where she kind of
fixes ghost do you think it has
something to do with that's what I've
been thinking about does it have
something to do with that is it that
situation maybe she took something that
now is inside of her that he's like you
stole the this from me and you left and
now I'm trying to get it back because I
need that piece to get out of this
hellhole I'm not saying that the
quantumania is a hell hole but are you
saying I mean it kind of is are you
saying that she stole his immortality
regenerating abilities yes I think it's
something like that it has to be
something big and adjacent to that so
because I was like why
she's she's uh she's the most wanted
right now she as soon as she went back
in there I was like she stole something
something to try to get herself out and
she's smart she's an engineer too so I'm
like it's something that she knew could
get her out or something to help her get
that signal because she still was able
to like contact her slightly uh uh Janet
and um the daughter
wasp but no the daughter was uh hope
hope yeah so it's like it was there a
little bit and it was something that I
think she stole from Kang and he's like
give it back because I need to get the
hell out of here but I also think he's
gonna try killing her because of it
my uh my theory coming out of d23 was
that it was Ramona rensslayer because I
think that there is a a connection there
that he feels that maybe his rival he
remains took his love for him uh and
like okay imprisoned her as a judge and
he remains TDA that's still my favorite
Theory because like I love my headphones
wait a minute I got too excited
I got so excited I pulled out my
headphones I'm so sorry I love it oh I
do that all the time my ears just kind
of like steam flies out and then these
yeah just go flying I've seen you do
that you've seen it yeah you saw it uh
okay I think it's like Damon Lindelof
who's the showrunner he he worked on
Lost he worked on HBO's Watchmen and on
the leftovers and I believe it was him
who said the the greatest answer to a
mystery in a TV show or in a story is
not a what it's a who and you see that a
lot in some of the best stories like
remember in uh in Daredevil season one
on Netflix when they're like what is
black sky and then they open the crate
and it's a little kid and it's like oh
like that that's such a cool thing to
reveal when it's a person yeah um so I
like that theory a lot it's just based
off of this trailer like I don't know
what world Janet would have with with
rensslayer I think it's a piece of
technology yeah I also okay I get it
love makes you do crazy things I guess I
wanna I I needed and maybe they're just
not playing in the trailer because I
understand that maybe that's too
revealing to put in the trailer is that
it's all because of ravona that's from
Loki season one but I'm like I need I
need to I need more I need more
reasoning I need more justification
because I did not see it at all in Loki
and then from the trailer it's like
there's I don't think it's love I think
it's genuinely like we thought that
there was multiple kings in the quantum
realm and they're all just beefing for a
minute and by multiple maybe like two or
three
um so I was like oh Janet has something
that has that will make it able for one
of them to get out and they're all
fighting to get Janet to go get it to
get out
um and so I was like that's where I was
leaning but I I like the idea of a love
story because there was
oh my God it was a long ago that I read
this but there is I think a brief part
in a comic about him being in love and
like going back in time a bunch and
doing stuff for her but I can't remember
I can't remember don't quote me on it
don't quote me on it but yeah there's
like a 60s comic I mean rensslayer's
hunter ID was a23 and Avengers 23 in the
60s is when rensslayer is introduced and
she's introduced as like Kang's like
unrequited love like she's a princess
she Kings into her she's like no thanks
and then he's always pissed off about
that and like why would they name this
character rivona rensslayer in The TBA
if they didn't want her to have a king
connection
it's going to it's going to that yeah it
absolutely so maybe not in this story
though I I think based off of this
trailer there's some kind of piece of
technology that uh he needs to escape
the quantum realm it feels like Kang is
trapped in the quantum realm he's built
this Army he wants to use it to invade
the Multiverse and like conquer
everything but the reason he hasn't done
that yet is that he's trapped he's stuck
there and I think we see a moment where
Janet looks up at the sky guy it looks
like someone is Crash Landing and it
looks like that's she's alone on a farm
this is her early years when she was in
the quantum realm I think she's seen
Kang's arrival and they had some kind of
relationship and then maybe she saw the
danger in him it's like okay you're
staying here but I think that's like
yeah I like the idea that maybe it was
some kind of like what something she
took back with her his healing
technology and he can't withstand the
journey out of the quantum realm and the
breakdown I posed a theory that like Ms
minutes is his Navigator and she took
his minutes or she hid Ms minutes
somewhere in the quantum realm maybe the
TVA is in the quantum realm she hit him
his minutes in there he can't get in
there uh and like he needs his minutes
to navigate him like his little RTD2 I
like that you know what I was also
thinking for your theory with ravona
what if it was ravona they gave him that
scar or those scars because she did have
like a weapon that was kind of like it
looked like knives it looked like knives
she used her high school pin and goes
she said I work at this school and did
sliced him and that's where the pen is
just always there okay it's it's very
comical yes it is but also I like the
ideas like that pen was more than just
the representation of the school she
worked out it's also the knife or this
benches to slice his face but I in a
different Universe it could have been
like she's like because she yeah she
definitely blew him off at first she was
like stop like she could have sliced his
face don't don't don't don't throw it
away completely I love that theory so
much I love that it would be red Slayer
who gave him those cigars so we have
just one more topic we want to talk
about first we want to thank Bluetooth
for sponsoring this episode while you
may need to shrink down to visit the
quantum realm you don't always want to
shrink to enter the bedroom realm this
episode is also brought to you by
Bluetooth Bluetooth is a unique online
service that delivers the same active
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis putting
triple tablets and a diffraction of the
cost you can take them anytime day or
night so you can plan ahead or be ready
ready for whatever an opportunity arises
the process is simple you sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
license medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive a
prescription within days so it's all
done online no visits to the doctor's
office no awkward conversations no wait
in line at the pharmacy Bluetooth
tablets are made in the USA and prepared
and shipped direct to your door in a
discrete package so if you could benefit
from some extra confidence when it's
time to perform Bluetooth can help and
we've got a special deal for our fans
try Bluetooth free when you use our
promo code Marvel at checkout just pay
the five dollars in shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code Marvel to
receive your first month free visit
bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information we thank
Bluetooth for sponsoring this podcast
and we all want to feel good in our
clothes right but it's not always easy
to find the right fit that's why you
should check out Rhone the dress shirt
was due for a radical reinvention and
Rowan stepped up to the challenge
Rowan's commuter shirt is the most
comfortable breathable and flexible
shirt known to man Roan's comfortable
four-way stretch fabric provides
breathability and flexibility that
leaves you free to enjoy what life
throws your way from your work time to
your free time with ruins wrinkle
release technology wrinkles disappear as
you stretch and wear the shirt it's that
easy Roan is 100 machine washable so you
can ditch the dry cleaner all together
other producer Zach loves his commuter
shirt because he can go from work
straight to dinner with the in-laws
feeling fresh and looking his best which
I mean that's really just a compliment
to Zach because he can look fresh and
his best in whatever he wears but you
know the Rhone shirt doesn't hurt
doesn't hurt the commuter shirt can get
you through any work day and straight to
whatever comes next head to rhone.com
Marvel and use the promo code Marvel to
save 20 off your entire order that's 20
off your entire order when you head to
rhone.com Marvel and use a promo code
Marvel it's time to find your corner
office Comfort all right Jess just one
question I want to leave us with the
trailer did not answer it I really
thought the first trailer would at least
address this what is quantumania what is
it what is it referring to in this movie
uh okay okay okay okay okay okay it's
okay so a piece of me when I first heard
this was like oh they just wanted a
really crazy title like fast like how
fast 10 you're the Fast and Furious 10th
movie is fast 10 it's like fast in I was
like maybe they just want something
crazy but then I also see that scene
where you see that giant
um Ant-Man that's turning into shreds
like uh uh like read from Multiverse and
Madness and you're just like okay and
Below him is a bunch of other little
Kings so a bunch of other little
ant-mans running alongside of him so I'm
like are they just gonna start breaking
through different portals in the quantum
realm that Kang has created once because
like as storytelling goes he's gonna hit
like his climax part for Kang and I'm
like is it just gonna be like Mysterio
did to Spider-Man and just create like a
bunch of mirrored walls dimensions and
like portals that lead to different
things and just because he controls time
and he controls time in the quantum
realm it looks like from what he said so
I'm like okay he's just gonna be
altering everything so it's just going
to be like Quantum realm Quantum Mania
if that makes sense I think it does I
think you're on to something Jess my
first instinct is that this city is just
gonna be called quantumania but I'm like
what a dumb name for a city why don't I
just call it chronopolis yeah literally
please just do it why won't they do it
or call it why won't they sayopolis or
something like that you can call it
whatever he wants didn't Jeff loveness
say it was it was chronopolis am I wrong
I think he has said that before or at
least he said it's like based on
chronopolis chronopolis is like uh
something that would be fun to revisit
whereas quantumania would seem specific
to this movie to call it quantumania
okay um but it also feels like we're
just we're getting we're ending phase
four with wakanda forever the name of
the of the setting as in the title of
the movie however my thinking for
quantumania is that it refers to what
you were talking about this moment where
it seems like Scott is being tortured in
this kind of we don't know if it's just
uh projection Visions thing or these are
actual Ant-Man uh Ant-Man variants from
across the mall I'm gonna say these are
actual ambient variants from across the
Multiverse that are have all been kind
of like confined in this place maybe
sucked here by Kang or trapped here by
past versions of Ant-Man who have tried
to do this and he's just like all right
add another to the pile you're the
you're the 13th 31st Ant-Man to try to
do this I'm so tired of King just
throwing people into different worlds
when they're bad
when it's got a bite him in the butt
eventually if he just keeps doing this
he keeps just creating a world being
like well here you go that would be so
sick that would be so sick if that's
just a bunch of ant-mans yeah I think
that's gotta be it and a lot of people
pointed this out the word quantumania
has ant and man in the word true AMT
then um wait no does it yes
I looked at it closely quantumania so I
love this idea and I and I started to
talk about this in the breakdown that I
love you you know they keep comparing
Ant-Man to Spider-Man and the MCU they
do it in this trailer Russell goes thank
you Spider-Man and then in Infinity War
or no it was end game where they're like
wait there's an Ant-Man and a Spider-Man
like that's kind of a thing where it's
the bug-themed Avengers who kind of get
compared and obviously Spider-Man's way
cooler but right now Spider-Man is like
everyone knows there's a Spider-Man and
everyone has forgotten who Peter Parker
is from the spell so Pete what makes
Peter Parker unique and we learn about
this in no way home is that he has a
spider's sense obviously he's unique in
a lot of ways but across the Multiverse
Peter Parker has this spider sense that
is a shared arachno frequency with all
Peter Parker's Miles Morales Gwen
Stacy's everyone who's a spider
something in the universe in the
Multiverse Peter Parker has this kind of
like innate hive mind with them and we
saw this a little bit in no way home
where they all three of them get the
spider sense at the same time when uh
when the the bad guys are coming into
the Statue of Liberty they're all kind
of linked that way that's why they can
kind of complete each other's sentences
that's why they go like hey him me you
him what I think there's gonna be
something with Ant-Man as well and that
when he's in this realm where all these
other Ant-Man are running around he like
ants in an ant colony have a way to kind
of like telepath ethically communicate
with each other we all already saw a
version of this with like Hank Pym and
Scott link and yes communicate
telepathically with these ants to direct
them and and I think now ant-man's new
suit operates on that technology I don't
think he has the buttons in his hands
anymore he has it on his chest kind of
like what Tony Stark had with the mark
uh 50 and then the mark 80 I think is
what he left with it's a neural link and
I think quantumania is going to be the
word for what it what happens when the
Ant-Man variants connect with each other
using that hive mind quantumania is the
word for when we're able to connect
quantumly with our brains I am so
obsessed I love that I love this might
be my favorite episode of inside Marvel
which is insane but this has been a fun
one holy [ __ ] that it might be reaching
I just think like no when they reveal
the word in the movie It's Gonna feel
like a victory and we're all gonna
scream quanta Mania do you think though
they'll probably even do like some sort
of thing at the very end or something
somewhere where it's like quantumania
and then the letters fall and it's like
Ant Man
I think he's getting pruned okay I think
Kang is like shooting fish in a barrel
and he's just like do you think that's
what happened to that wrapped person at
the bar in the trailer you know what I'm
talking about I think he was like about
to be tortured and keng's like just
kidding just kidding he started this is
insane I love this I love this and I
want this so bad please do not change I
changed the movie if that's not gonna
happen look change the movie it's not
gonna happen we're gonna we're gonna go
with this but here's the deal and I and
I joked about this at the end of the
breakdown um the more uh more of a
mystery box a movie or a show is where
they're just presenting weird Landscapes
and we don't know what the realm is the
crazier the theories are remember ahead
of Loki and we're watching that or
before one Division and we're like
sitcom is this like what at least Wanda
was kind of obvious with the sitcoms
it's like Loki I remember like certain
episodes I was like what the hell is
gonna happen
I'm getting so mad especially when they
when they got trapped on the planet I
was like how are they gonna get off this
planet that's about to explode
man
they're gonna die oh my God we're in a
new dawn for Theory crafted right now
we're gonna come up with even crazier
ideas than this to explain what this
movie is this is insane a lot of fun I
love this I love that so much
I oh my God I wanted to happen so bad oh
my God I wanted to happen so bad it
better I um I'm so excited I know this
this trailer seemed like a sleeper for a
lot of people they're like why is there
Elton John music in this do we really
need a third Ant-Man movie it seems to
betray the the goofy San Francisco Heist
Vibes of uh of the first still heisty
it's still heisty it's just time heisty
it's just time it's just time heisty
it's uh they're like it looks too much
like Spy Kids and here's my thought on
it I really care too much about like
vfxiness of it I care about like
specific production design choices and I
like seeing these weirdos with these
with the weird uh screw head dude the
light the tanks yeah the light Android
uh and then like I have blue swishy
water tanks that like feed into it like
lawn mowers uh spraying sod in there
like what the farm with slugs on it
they're they're surfing a manta ray they
went to the Marvel the Marvel VFX team
and said draw whatever you want and
we're gonna choose like seven and they
they said okay
I'm very excited to learn more about
these characters and if they're all like
from different if they were born in the
quantum realm where they came from
outside like how in um solar opposites
how the little kid is stealing all the
people and put him in the wall I'm like
are people just being taken into the
quantum realm and just forced to stay
there I think they they were so hated in
their universes that they just kind of
fell through they were looking for an
escape and then they're like fine I'll
just shrink out of them shrink into this
and they found the lint trap of the
quantum Realm oh and now they're like I
hate it it's ruled by a crazy person or
some of them are like I'm alive now I
love it here
oh beautiful Bill Murray's here no where
is he Jess this has been a delight
talking quantumania with you I can't
wait to do it more over the next couple
months but we will leave it there for
this episode of inside Marvel follow
Jess at Lulu underscore Clements you can
follow me at eavos Mt will be back with
us he's just on vacation this week so
let's all wish him well subscribe to
inside Marvel wherever you get your
podcast thank you for watching thank you
Spider-Man bye
foreign